DEREK MURRAY: OK.
Hello, everyone.
I hope you all had a nice lunch.
So as Zach said,
I'm Derek Murray.
I've been working on TensorFlow
for a little over two years
now.
And in that time, one of
the most interesting things
I've worked on has been
distributed TensorFlow.
So that's what I'm going
to be talking about today.
Before I get
started, I just want
to get a sense of the room.
So how many people here
have ever written or run
a distributed
TensorFlow program?
All right.
I'm going to say that's,
like, 5% of you, maybe.
I'm sorry to the folks
on the livestream who
can't put your hands up and
give me this immediate feedback.
But if you want to
follow me on Twitter,
that would send a
very strong signal.
OK.
So why-- thank you.
So why do I care so much
about distributed TensorFlow?
Well, it's what enables
us here at Google
to scale up the training
and inference of machine
learning models on these
futuristic-looking machines
in our data centers.
And since we made it open
source just under a year ago,
you've been able to run it on
your clusters at home as well.
And why might you want to run
TensorFlow on lots of computers
at the same time?
Zach kind of gave you a
clue in the introduction.
The most common
reason is that you
want to increase the
throughput of training
your models to train them faster
by harnessing a load of GPUs
and train that
model in parallel.
So this graph is taken
from our OSDI paper
that we wrote last year.
And it shows how the
training throughput
of the Inception_V3 model
scales up using up to 200 GPUs.
And actually this is, I
think, TensorFlow .8, .9,
was the version
we used for this.
So the numbers have
only gotten better
with all the improvements
you heard about this morning.
So the Inception model is
nice because it fits neatly
in a single GPU.
We also have more
complicated things
like the neural machine
translation model, which
Megan mentioned in the keynote.
And this model is
so big, it benefits
from being split across up to
eight GPUs in the same server.
And then we use multiple
servers to train
that model in parallel.
If you're interested
in finding out more
about models like
this, Eugene is
going to be talking
about the LSTMs that
make up each layer of the
translation model later on.
Another reason you might
want to use lots of computers
is that your model is
so big that it doesn't
fit in a single machine.
So this is true for a lot
of the wide and deep models
that [INAUDIBLE] is going to
be talking about later today.
And these use large
embedding matrices,
that can be gigabytes or
tens of gigabytes in size,
to map sparse data like, in
this example, pairs of apps
that users have used
together to map those down
to [INAUDIBLE]
representation that we
can train with a traditional
deep neural network.
And then, why settle
for very large models
when you can train outrageously
large models as well?
So our colleague Noam Shazeer
has a bit of a reputation for,
like, pushing the envelope
on making large models
practical to train.
And he uses tricks like
distributed candidate
sampling to scale up to very
large output class sets.
Recently he's been
working with a team--
I think they just got a
paper into ICLR 2017--
to train neural networks with
tens of billions of parameters,
using techniques like
conditional computation
and mixtures of experts to
get even better performance
on some language modeling
and translation tasks.
So what all these
examples have in common
is that they take advantage
of the flexibility
distributed TensorFlow gives you
to train bigger models faster
and to better accuracy.
And this flexibility,
you know, it's
great if you're an
expert user, but it
can make distributed TensorFlow
look a little bit daunting.
It actually is a very
simple, very minimalist core,
but it wears a lot of the
complexity of distributed
computing on the outside.
So while we do have some nice
high-level APIs, sometimes
for the really
cutting-edge stuff
you have to kind of get in
there and move some tensors
around using the
low-level TensorFlow API.
And so my aim over the
next 20, 25 minutes or so
is to give you a bottom-up
introduction to distributed
TensorFlow.
I'm going to show you how the
core concepts you might be used
to in single-process TensorFlow
translate to the distributed
world.
I'll give you some ideas for
how to deal with the complexity
that ensues.
So I just claimed that
distributed TensorFlow
has a minimalist core.
What did I mean by that?
Well, let's say I've
got just one computer,
and it's got a GCPU device
and a GPU device in it.
And if I want to write a
TensorFlow program to use these
devices, I can put these little
with_tf.device annotations
in my code, so that
for this example,
the variables go on the CPU,
and the math goes on the GPU,
where it's going to run faster.
Then, when I come
to run this program,
TensorFlow splits up the
graph between the devices
and it puts in the necessary
DNA between the devices
to run it for me.
Now what happens when my
clicker runs out of battery?
OK, we're moving over here.
I think.
So when we have multiple--
no, is it working again?
Ah, OK.
Just a little bit of lag.
Sorry about that, folks.
All right.
So what happens if you
have multiple machines?
Let's say, for reasons that
will become apparent later,
that we want to
take those variables
and put them on the CPU
device of a different process.
Well, TensorFlow treats the
remote devices exactly the same
as the local ones.
All I have to do is add just
a little bit of information
to these device
names, and the runtime
will put the variables
in a different process,
splitting up the graph
between the devices
in the different
processes and adding
the necessary communication.
In this case, it
will be using GRPC
to transfer tensors between
the processes instead of DNA
from the GPU device.
So there you have it.
Using distributed
TensorFlow is just
a simple matter of getting
all of your device placements
exactly right.
And yeah, I heard a wry chuckle.
Yeah, I'm sure you know
exactly how easy that can be,
if you've ever written
a TensorFlow program.
All right.
I should have put a sarcasm
tag in there or something.
But OK.
Maybe we should
back up a little bit
and see how we can make
this problem a bit simpler.
Well, one thing we can do
is we can take inspiration
from other systems, including
our previous system, which
was called DisBelief.
And in DisBelief we had two
distinct kinds of processes.
We had parameter servers
and worker replicas.
And parameter servers are
responsible for holding
onto all of the model
state, so the parameters,
and updating them in response
to incoming gradients,
whereas the worker
replicas, they
would do all the intensive
part of the computation.
So they would do the
input processing.
They'd calculate the
loss for your network.
And they'd do the backprop
to actually calculate
those gradients.
In TensorFlow, we can
mimic this architecture
by designating some
of the processes
to be what we call PS tasks.
And we put the variable
nodes and the ops that
update them on those tasks.
And then we put the rest of
the graph, the nodes that
do the pre-processing, the
forward, and the backprop
on the worker tasks, which
tend to be more powerful
and have multi-course
CPUs and GPUs.
And one big difference
between how we did things
in DisBelief and
in TensorFlow is
that in DisBelief, the parameter
servers and the worker replicas
were two completely
different programs.
They were basically two
loosely-coupled distributed
systems that had very
little in common.
And you would program them
by very different APIs.
In TensorFlow, the PS
and the worker tasks
run exactly the same code.
They are just
servers that you can
send little bits of
TensorFlow graph to,
and it will react to
those bits of graph
and execute them very quickly.
And this gives us a
lot of flexibility.
So a PS task, for
example, we could
have it use a GPU to accelerate
some of the parameter update
computations.
Or we could have the workers
store some state locally
to avoid network traffic,
to cache some of the reads.
Or we could even cut
out the PS altogether
and use direct connections
between the workers,
if we had a network that
was fast enough to deal
with that communication.
But with that said,
the old PS-worker split
has been really useful for
training a lot of our models.
And so we've developed a decent
amount of software support
around this idea.
And I'm going to show you
now some examples of how we
do that in the next few slides.
All right.
So the first idea
that works pretty well
for distributed
training, particularly
when a single model will
fit in a single machine,
is replication.
So just like in DisBelief, we
take the compute-intensive part
of the model training, the
forwards and the backprop,
and we make a copy of it
in multiple worker tasks,
so that each task works on a
different subset of the data.
This is data parallel
training, like we
were doing for that Inception
example back at the start.
And the simplest thing,
simplest way we can achieve this
is by doing something I'm going
to call in-graph replication.
The reason for this name
will hopefully become
self-explanatory when I--
or maybe just explanatory when
I tell you what the code does.
We start by putting the
variables on a PS task,
like the earlier example.
And this is just so that
they're in a central location
that they can be accessed
by all of the workers.
And then the easiest way to
do the in-graph replication
is just to split up
a batch of input data
into equal-sized chunks,
loop over the worker tasks,
and use this
tf.device string here
to put a subgraph on each worker
to compute a partial result.
And then finally,
we combine together
all of the partial
results into a single loss
value that we optimize by
using a standard TensorFlow
optimizer.
And sure enough, when you
tell it to compute the loss,
TensorFlow will split up the
graph across the workers,
and it will run across these
worker tasks and the PS all in
parallel.
So in-graph replication
is pretty easy to achieve.
It's not a big modification
to your existing programs.
And it works pretty well up
to a small number of replicas.
If you want to replicate
across all the GPUs
in a single machine, then
maybe in-graph replication
is the way to go.
But one of the
things we found out
when we tried to apply this
technique to a large model
like Inception_V3, and
we tried to scale it up
to a couple of
hundred machines, was
that this graph gets really
big if you have to materialize
all the replicas in it.
And the client gets
bogged down trying
to coordinate the computation
and to build this whole graph.
And that's why we came up with
an alternative approach, which
is called between-graph
replication.
This is currently what
we use most internally.
It's what we
recommend in Cloud ML.
And it's also what
our high-level APIs
are designed to do.
So if you've ever
written an NPI program,
between-graph replication should
be a kind of familiar concept.
So instead of running one
all-powerful client program
that knows about all
of the worker replicas,
we run a smaller client
program on each task.
And that client
program just builds up
the graph for a single
replica of the model.
And this client
program is essentially
doing the same thing, with one
key difference in the device
placement.
So it takes kind of the
non-parameter part of the graph
and it puts it on
the local devices,
or the devices that are
local to that worker replica.
And so now when you
run it, each program
is running its smaller
graph independently,
and they get mapped
to different subsets
of the devices that intersect
on the PS task in the middle.
There's a little bit
of magic here which
I should probably
explain, in the interest
of full disclosure.
So each replica places its
variables on the same PS task.
And when you're running in
distributed mode, by default,
any two clients that
create a variable
with the same name
on the same device
will share the same backing
storage for that variable.
And if you're doing
replicated training,
this is exactly what you want.
So the updates from task 0, when
it's applying its gradients,
will be visible in
task 1, and vice versa.
So you'll train faster.
But this brings us
to another issue,
which is how do you decide
where to put the variables?
So far, I've just been
putting them on jobPS task 0
and setting that as
the explicit device
string for the variables.
But device strings,
you know, they're
all very good if you want
to put all of your ops
in one particular location.
But you often want to
do things like have
more than one PS task, say
if you want to distribute
the work of updating
the variables
or distribute the network
load of fetching them
to the workers.
So instead of passing a
device string to tf.device,
you can also pass
a device function.
And we use these to build more
complicated, more sophisticated
placement strategies.
Device functions are pretty
general, very powerful.
They let you basically
customize the placement
of every single op in the graph.
That makes them a little
bit tricky to use.
So one of the
things we've done is
to provide a few
pre-canned device functions
to make your life a bit easier.
And the simplest
of these is called
tf_train_replica_device_setter.
And its job is to
assign variables
to PS tasks in a round-robin
fashion as they're created.
One nice thing about
this device function
is you can just wrap your
entire model building
code in this with block.
It only affects the variables,
puts them on PS tasks.
And the rest of your ops in
the graph will go on a worker.
So if you're doing
between-graph replication,
this takes care
of it all for you.
So for this program,
it will assign devices
to the parameters
as they're created.
So the first weight
matrix will go on task 0.
A bias vector will go on task 1.
The second weight's on task 2.
And then the second
bias is back on task 0.
This is obviously not
an optimal balanced load
for these variables, neither
in terms of the memory usage
or the amount of work
that would need to be
done to update these variables.
And just think, if we only
had two PS tasks here--
I guess I should have
drawn a diagram--
we'd end up with an even worse
case, because all the weights
would be on task 0, and all the
biases would be on the other.
We'd have an even bigger
imbalance between those tasks.
So clearly, we can
do better here.
And one of the ways that we've
provided to achieve a more
balanced load is to use
something called a load
balancing strategy.
And this is an optional argument
to the replica device setter.
Right now we only have, I think,
a simple greedy strategy that
does a kind of
online bin packing
based on the number of
bytes in your parameters.
And it leads to this
more balanced outcome.
Each of the weight matrices
is put on a separate PS task,
and the biases get packed
together on task 1.
It's a lot more balanced,
and this should give you
a lot better performance.
And so far, I've only talked
about relatively small
variables that all
fit in a single task.
But what about these
outrageously large model
parameters, things like
the large embeddings
that might be tens
of gigabytes in size?
Well, to deal with
these, we have
something called partitioners.
They do exactly what it
sounds like they would do.
If you create a variable with
a partitioner, like this one
here, TensorFlow will split
the large logical variable
into three concrete
parts and assign them
to different PS tasks.
And one nice thing about
doing things this way
is if you take that
embedding variable
and then you pass it to some
of the embedding-related
functions, like
embedding look-up,
for example, it
will take advantage
of the knowledge about
the fact that it's
going to be
partitioned, and it will
offload some of the
embedding look-up computation
and the gradients to
the parameter server
devices themselves.
All right.
That was a lot of detail
about device placement.
But it is a very big topic.
I guess you could say it's a
combinatorially large problem
domain that we have to solve.
The main thing I
want you to take away
is that the
tf_train_replica_device_setter
is this simple heuristic that
works for a lot of distributed
training use cases.
And you can customize
it if you need
to by providing these optional
strategies for things like load
balancing and partitioning, or
even writing your own device
functions that override the
simple policies we provide.
And this is definitely an
area where we're always
on the lookout for new and
better device placement
policies.
So if you do end up
implementing your own
and you think it might
be generally useful,
we really encourage you to
send it as a pull request,
and we can add it
to the set of tools
that people have to
make their lives easier.
All right.
So you've built your graph.
You've got all of
the devices set.
And now you want to
go ahead and run it.
But when you create a TensorFlow
session using code like this,
that session will only
know about the devices
in a local machine.
And let's say you have
200 computers sitting
idle over there.
How do you make it
use those computers?
The answer is that you create
this thing called a TensorFlow
server in each of
those machines.
And you configure those
servers in a cluster
so that they can communicate
over the network.
Now, looking at
it in more detail,
the first thing we need to do
is to provide a cluster spec.
This is something that tells
TensorFlow about the machines
that you want to run on.
A cluster spec is
really just a dictionary
that maps the names of jobs--
so that's things like worker
and PS, in this example--
to a list of one or more network
addresses that correspond
to the tasks in each job.
Now, we don't
actually expect you
to type in all of these
addresses by hand.
It gets kind of error prone.
But in the next talk,
Jonathan's going
to be showing you how a
cluster manager like Kubernetes
or Mesos will do this for you.
And if you're using
a cluster manager,
internally we use a
cluster manager called Borg
that a lot of this
stuff was inspired by.
So typically, your
cluster manager
will run an instance
of your program
on each machine in the cluster,
giving it the same cluster
spec.
And then it'll start
a TensorFlow server
in each program.
It'll pass it a particular
job name and task
index that matches the
address of the local machine
in that cluster.
And then finally, when
you create your session,
you specify the local
server's address
as the target, which is
what enables it to connect
through that server to any
of the machines mentioned
in the cluster spec.
And then you're good to go.
So your session run
call can run code
on any device in
the entire cluster.
And typically, what
the worker will do
is it'll start a training
loop that just iterates
over its partition of the
data, running a training
op over and over again.
OK.
So that's what a
worker looks like.
PS task is much simpler.
So PS tasks simply--
they have basically
no client code.
They just respond to
incoming bits of graph
that are sent to them
by other workers.
So in this case, you
just build the server.
You say it's job name PS.
And then you call
join on the server.
And all that does is it
blocks waiting for connections
to come in from other
nodes in the cluster.
And actually, it's a bit weird.
So I deal with a lot of
questions on stack overflow.
And one of the common
ones is, can you
show me where in the
implementation of server.join
the parameter server code lives?
And if you go and look
at it, it's like, five,
10 lines of C++.
It just does some
error checking,
and then it blocks on
a couple of threads.
It joins a couple of threads.
That's why it's called join.
But it's a reasonable
misconception,
because this is your PS task.
Well, what's that
actually doing?
Well, this highlights something
quite important about how
distributed TensorFlow works.
So parameter
servers, everything,
all the behavior of
a parameter server,
is not implemented at the
low level in these servers
or in the execution
engine, but instead it's
built out of TensorFlow
programming primitives,
as these little bits
of data flow graph
that a worker ships
to a server to say,
manage some parameters for
me and update them this way.
And that, representing the
way we program the parameter
servers as little fragments
of data flow graph,
is what gives us
the flexibility.
So unless you change everything
about how parameter management
is implemented, if you want
to customize the optimization
algorithm, or maybe
change the synchronization
scheme for applying
the updates, you
can do that just by
changing the graph.
And we've gained a
lot of performance
by doing that in some
of our algorithms.
All right.
So now that your
servers are listening,
your sessions are all created,
and your training loop
is running, are we done?
Well, whenever you run some
long-running training job
on a set of machines, I hope you
take the wise words of Leslie
Lamport to heart, and
always use a saver
in any long-running
training process.
So a saver, for those of you
who haven't seen that before,
is just what you use to write
out a checkpoint of your model
parameters to disk.
The same saver can be used for
local and distributed training,
but it has a couple of useful
features in distributed mode
that I want to highlight.
The first one is that
you'll almost certainly
want to set sharded equals true
when you create your saver.
So in this example, we
have three PS tasks,
and so sharded equals
true tells TensorFlow,
write the checkpoint
in three shards,
each containing all
the variables from one
particular parameter server.
And that means that the
parameter servers can
write directly to
the file system,
and we don't have to collect
all of the values in one place
in order to write them out.
So actually the default
behavior is kind of pessimal,
because if you set
sharded equals false,
it will bring all of the
variables into one save op,
meaning they have to be
materialized in memory at one
process before it
writes the first byte.
And if you have these
really big models,
well, that's a sure way
to have a memory error.
So always use
sharded equals true.
That's if you
remember one thing.
OK, second, if you are using
between-graph replication,
you now have a choice
of several worker tasks
that could be responsible
for writing this checkpoint.
And by convention, we give
some extra responsibilities
to worker task 0.
We just picked that because
there's always a worker task
0 in our jobs, because that's
where the numbering starts.
And we call it the chief worker.
And so the chief worker has a
few important maintenance tasks
that it has to carry out,
doing things like writing
checkpoints, in this case.
Also things like
initializing the parameters
at the start of day and logging
summaries for TensorBoard.
These are all done by the chief.
And then the last
thing to note is
that savers now support a
variety of distributed file
systems.
So instead of writing
to a local file,
you can write to
Google Cloud Storage,
let's say if you're
running on Cloud ML.
Or if you're running on
top of a Hadoop cluster,
you can write straight to HDFS.
And using a distributed
file system here
is a smart idea, because it
gives you more durable storage.
You're not going to lose
your model checkpoints if one
of the machines goes on fire.
It also makes it easier
to read a checkpoint
from another machine.
So one common pattern we use is
we have a separate evaluation
task that's running
on a separate machine,
and it just goes and
picks up the latest
checkpoint of the model and
evaluates the test set on that.
So this makes that kind of
loosely-coupled coordination
a bit easier.
All right.
So you're writing
checkpoints now.
That's a good step.
That guards against failure.
But what actually happens
when you experience a fault?
In the best case--
there are a few
cases to consider.
And the best case is that one
of your non-chief workers fails.
And the reason this
is the best case
is because these
workers are typically
sort of effectively stateless.
So when a non-chief worker
comes back up, all it has to do
is contact all the PS
tasks again and carry on
as if nothing happened.
And usually we have
a cluster manager
that will restart a failed
process as soon as it crashes.
If a PS task fails,
that's a little worse,
because PS tasks are stateful.
All the workers are relying on
them to send their gradients
and get the new values
of the parameters.
So in this case, the chief
is responsible for noticing
the failure.
It interrupts training
on all of the workers,
and restores all the PS tasks
from the last checkpoint.
The trickiest case is when
the chief fails, because we've
given it all of these
extra responsibilities,
and we need to make sure that
we get back to a good state
when it comes back up.
So training could continue
when the chief is down,
but when it comes
back up, we don't
know if, for example,
another task has failed.
So it has to go and restore
bits from the last checkpoint.
So the thing we do is
just to interrupt training
when the chief fails.
And when it comes back up,
we restore from a checkpoint,
just like a parameter
server fails.
This is a pretty simple and
a pretty conservative scheme.
And it only really works if your
machines are reliable enough
that they aren't
failing all the time.
And it keeps the logic for
recovery really, really simple.
But depending on how common
failures are in your cluster
environment, maybe it
would be beneficial to use
a different policy that tries
to keep the training job running
without interruption.
And I just want to sort of
provoke some thinking here.
One thing you could do is maybe
use a configuration management
server, something like
Apache ZooKeeper or Etcd,
to choose a chief
by leader election,
rather than saying it
always has to be worker 0.
And then if you
did that, you could
pass on the responsibility of
being a chief when one of them
fails, and kind of do a
failover without interrupting
the training process.
If somebody wanted to try that
out and contribute it back,
that would be just great.
But if you do like
that simple policy,
we've got something for you.
So you can use
this recently added
MonitoredTrainingSession
class to automate the recovery
process.
So going back to our simple,
single-process example,
when you create a TensorFlow
session, usually what you do
is you explicitly
initialize the variables,
or restore them
from a checkpoint,
before you start training.
And MonitoredTrainingSession
looks a lot like a regular tf
session, but you'll see that
it kind of takes a little bit
more information in
its constructor-- needs
to know if it's
the chief or not,
needs to know what
server you're using.
And you'll note that there's no
init op in the program anymore.
Instead, what the
MonitoredTrainingSession
is going to do is it
will automatically
ensure that all of the variables
have been initialized either
from their initial
values, like the randomly
initialized variables, or by
restoring them from the latest
checkpoint if one is available,
before it returns control back
to the user.
And it does something slightly
different depending on
if you're the chief or not.
So if you're the
chief, it's going
to go and look and see
if there is a checkpoint,
or it's going to run
the initializers.
If you're not the chief,
it just sits there waiting
until the chief does its work.
And then as soon
as it's done, it
can carry on running
the training loop.
There's a lot of potential
for customization here.
So we support these
installable hooks
that you can attach either
when you create the session
or before or after doing
a session run call.
And the
MonitoredTrainingSession is
sort of a tastefully
curated set of these hooks
that makes distributed
training a bit easier.
So it comes with standard
hooks for writing a checkpoint
every 10 minutes, writing
summaries every 100 steps.
And if you want to, you
can customize its behavior
by adding more
hooks or replacing
the ones that are there.
OK, finally, by this
point, some of you
might be thinking, wow,
that is a lot of effort
that you have to go to
just to run training
on a distributed cluster.
Can it be easier?
And yeah, well, if you
do things from scratch,
and if you use
the low-level API,
there are a lot of things
that you have to take care of.
But fear not, because
as you might remember
from Martin's talk
this morning, we now
have these high-level
APIs that have
great support for training and
evaluation on a single machine.
And there's tf contrib
level support for training
on a distributed cluster.
So what does that look like?
Well, this distributed
training support
uses a recently added class
called Experiment to package up
the training and evaluation of
an estimator using a cluster.
So when you create
an experiment,
you bundle together an estimator
with some input functions.
You tell it how to read
a particular data set
for training and for evaluation.
You give it some more
configuration options.
And here you could specify
a little canned estimator
in a few lines, so this is
a pre-canned DNN classifier
with two hidden layers.
You could do
something more fancy
by passing in a
custom model function,
or you could even pass
a Keras model in there
to do distributed training.
And you wrap that in an
experiment function and pass
that function to something
called learn_runner.run, which,
if you're running on Cloud ML,
will pick up the configuration
from the environment and it will
run the appropriate low-level
APIs for you.
So your code can be
almost as simple as this.
It's probably, like,
five lines of boilerplate
that you'd need at the top
to run distributed training.
Actually, I've been told--
Martin told me that the contrib
function learn_runner is
going to change its name soon.
So I know we're
1.0, but we still
like changing names of things.
This code example is a
little bit more aspirational
than some of the
others, but hopefully it
gets across the idea
that the high-level APIs
can take care of a lot of
the gory details for you.
And so yeah.
I mean, these estimators are
great if your training process
follows a standard pattern.
And nine times
out of 10, they're
probably what you're going
to want to use when you're
running distributed TensorFlow.
So you can start
getting your program
running on nicely-lit data
centers like these in no time
at all.
But sometimes you're going
to want to bend the rules,
if you have some more
complicated requirements,
or you want to go
slightly outside the--
think slightly outside the box.
So in this talk,
I've shown you how
distributed TensorFlow
gives you the flexibility
to do just that.
You can scale training
out to hundreds of GPUs.
You can train outrageously large
models with tens of billions
of parameters.
And you can choose between
customizing every last detail
of the execution or defining
the whole training process
in just a few lines of code.
If you're interested in learning
a bit more about distributed
TensorFlow, I'd encourage
you to check out
these links, which cover
this sort of low-level system
architecture, the
low-level distributed
API and the high-level API.
But at this point, I'd like to
thank all of you in the room
and on the livestream
for listening.
Thanks, all, very much.
[APPLAUSE]